comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui regardez de qu'on va pas
l'on se parle de windows windows rose a
été lancée officiellement il ya peine
quelques jours alors ça dépend en
quelques mois vous regardez cette vidéo
mais mon nom je la tourne windows a été
annoncé il ya tout juste quelques jours
windows est un vrai tournant par rapport
à windows disque sorti il ya quelques
bonnes années interface qui est revu
corrigé de nouvelles fonctionnalités une
nouvelle philosophie potentiellement
pourra dire ça comme ça donc il va
arriver tout doucement il va être mis à
jour sur les machines d'abord les plus
récentes et ensuite les machines qui
sont arrivés un peu après un peu après
un peu après il ya un grand minimum pour
pouvoir prétendre à avoir windows on
sait avoir au minimum 4 gigas de ram
normalement ça devrait quand même plutôt
va mal se passer vous êtes sûrs d intel
à partir de la huitième génération et à
partir d'un amd reisen 2006 vous voulez
vérifier votre compatibilité dès
aujourd'hui vous avez un outil sur le
site de microsoft qui s'appelle pcf
comme ça vous pourrez savoir si vous
allez pouvoir venir vous installer un
windows roses dans votre machine alors
moi je vends les installions dans une de
mes bécane j'ai identifié dix points que
je voulais voir avec vous qui sont
intéressantes dit nouveautés
significatives qui nous permettront de
savoir si cette version de windows os
déjà est intéressante et réussie et
aboutis ou alors est ce qu'elle est ah
c'est loupé on va regarder ça et puis
regardez si elle est faite pour vous
s'il faut y aller tout de suite ou pas
alors il ya un truc qui est super
important et à savoir tout de suite on
se met d'accord il va y avoir des mises
à jour windows 11 il ya eu des bêta il
est arrivé de façon officielle
aujourd'hui donc elle est utilisable
mais il y aura des mises à jours qui
vont venir corriger quelques bugs
puisqu'il va y avoir une diffusion sur
un public un peu plus la regarder choses
qui vont venir remonter donc si votre
machine vous propose tout de suite un
windows rose et que vous êtes friands
vous pouvez y aller mais sachez que si
vous y allez dans quelques mois et bien
il y aura deux choses qui ont été mis à
jour qui ont été corrigés bon on va pas
perdre plus de temps de redescendre être
des points importants à regarder et on
va se plonger tout de suite les devants
le premier point ça va être un design
qui revue et corrigée qui est repensée
c'est notamment des animations qui vont
être plus fluide ça va être des bords
arrondis regardez vous les voyez là ça
peut paraître est du point de détail
mais ça a toute son importance et c'est
vraiment intéressant lorsque vous allez
ouvrir une fenêtre on va pas cela m en 6
grands d'un gradé vous ouvrez une
fenêtre bien vous à des animations qui
sont là hop là un petit zoom dézoom non
ça vous connaissez si vous avez machines
performantes ça apportera de la fluidité
les icônes ont été également retravaillé
il ya des choses qui sont plutôt bien
réussi d'autres un petit peu moins bien
on va se régaler ça dans quelques
instants et vous aussi un des nouveaux
sons qui sont arrivés autre nouveauté
c'est ce menu démarrer qui a été
complètement repensée regardez il est
centré vous ouvrez vous avez les
chercheuses qui est vraiment différent
alors en haut vous avez toutes vos
applications que vous venez vous
épinglez directement en dessous c'est
les recommandations qui vont arriver en
fonction des programmes que vous
utilisez et puis là vous avez toutes vos
applications c'est très très très épuré
c'est par exemple venir épinglé mon
enregistreur vocal je fais un petit clic
droit dessus eh bien je fait épingler au
menu démarrer je reviens ici et je vais
venir le retrouver à regarder je peux le
dire scrollé il est en bas alors vous
pouvez venir avoir plusieurs niveaux
peuvent venir en retirer on a ajouté
c'est très pratique donc là c'est
vachement bien la recherche aussi qui en
eau qui est vraiment très très simple on
pourra venir faire de la recherche dans
vos applications dont vos documents sur
le web également d'envoyer il ya un côté
qui est très très très simple et très
épuré une fois de plus des recherches
rapides pour venir traduire
convertisseur de devises un petit quizz
be l'idée ici c'est vraiment d'apporter
une expérience simple pas de pollution
votre bouton pour venir redémarrer qui
est situé juste la marche arrière et
même dans les recommandations pour en
avoir un petit peu plus toute la liste
de recommandations qui est là ils ont
vraiment cherché à épurer la chose et si
vous préférez la voir au centre en fait
un petit clic droit sur votre bas vous
avez les paramètres de la barre des
tâches comportement de la barre des
tâches pouvait venir la ligne est à
gauche bon comme c'était un peu avant on
revient surtout qu un peu plus standard
mais si ça vous perdre que ce soit au
centre vous pouvez bien le faire donc il
ya un côté pratique vous pouvez
également venir là masqués sans le
connaissez pas tout nouveau ça nous
ramène au troisième point parce
qu'effectivement on a ce menu démarrer
qui est centrée m'ont également cette
barre des tâches qui complètement
repensé lorsque vous cliquez ici sur
l'icône avec le wifi le son et la
batterie bien tout est regroupé en un
seul et même endroit ça me fait plutôt
bien vous voyez votre wifi vote
bluetooth promettent le mode avion
l'économie d'énergie l'assistant
concentration qui aussi nouveau un peu
comme ce qu'on trouve chez apple ici
avec une priorité uniquement avec des
alarmes uniquement et puis là on
désactive la question de l'accessibilité
vous avez également votre luminosité
bref tout-en-un ici qui est vachement
bien vue puis sur la droite vous cliquez
vous y retrouvez votre agenda et vos
notifications
donc ça c'est aussi pratique ils ont
regroupé ça pourra plus de lisibilité
bien d'autres éléments qui arrivent et
qui est super intéressant en termes de
productivité c'est la gestion du multi
fenêtres on va s'ouvrir
world regardez vous venez sur votre
petit bouton ici qui sert à grandir vous
bougez pas vous dit allez voir je te
mets à gauche on va venir ouvrir par
exemple les email pareil je laisse mon
petit curseur dessus j avais tu te mets
en eau et puis on va se mettre les gens
c'est rien mon navigateur qui va
s'ouvrir ici je me mets dessus et je dis
tu te mets en bas ça me permet de
travailler sur mon document à gauche
pour indexer les compagnies peu importe
on s'en fiche mais email en haut en bas
je vais pouvoir retrouver mon navigateur
donc bref je peux le disposer comme je
veux l'or là je le mets en 3 mais je
peux le mettre en quatre si je souhaite
le lot rétrécir et en termes de
productivité sur ça vachement bien il ya
d'autres éléments que je trouve
intéressant c'est de pouvoir avoir
plusieurs bureaux alors c'est pas
nouveau c'est déjà sur windows 10 manage
tout cas c'est mieux fait vous posez
dessus vous survolez et vous arrivez
dans votre univers là par exemple je
vous ai mis tout ce que j'avais autour
du travail donc j'ai regardé ma
configuration comme ça je reviens là je
me mets sur le gaming donc là je peux
mettre mes fenêtres kinnear disposer
comme je veux et pas être obligé de le
fermer donc ça ça me paraît plutôt
intéressant je me dis ah les plages en
ronde bosse et j'ai ma disposition
travail j'ai mon espace perso je peux en
créer plein en fonction des différentes
applications des différentes
configurations que je veux qu'on trouve
ça super intéressant autre élément
jetons super intéressant c'est les
widgets alors widgets ils vont être sur
la gauche vous venez là regardez vous
survolez les widgets vous appuyez vous
avez tous vos rides jette sur la partie
de gauche qui vont venir ici alors on
voit qu'on a le rang au on a une
recherche sur le web très simple
pourquoi pas il y en a des infos qu'on
peut dire personnalisé déplacer modifié
changer la météo j'ai des infos sur le
sport les photos j'ai les suggestions
qui est sûre la bourse pourquoi pas de
l'actualité bon j'ai un peu de people
avec gallas veut bien le faire mais ça
ne m'intéresse pas je regarde pas
intéressé et je peux avoir plein
d'autres articles de l'acte eu bon c'est
intéressant ça peut être potentiellement
perfectible mais sur l'idée je trouve ça
pas mal d'avoir ces widgets à gauche et
je peux venir en rajouter également si
je le souhaite regarder ce qu'il se
rajouter des widgets je peux venir
ajouter par exemple la circulation les
tâches à effectuer le contrôle parental
le calendrier outlook donc c'est
vachement bien 7e place avec les
fonctionnalités autour de tim steam ça a
pris une place centrale
et de la même manière à ce qu'on a on
retrouve aujourd'hui avec facetime sur
votre iphone notamment qui vous permet
et bien de communiquer avec des
personnes sur android de leur envoyer un
lien une invitation et bien nick leake
et au pouvoir l'utiliser mais c'est un
peu la même chose ici vous pouvez venir
inviter des personnes à vous rejoindre à
communiquer lors si vous êtes dans steam
vous pouvez avoir des visions l'audio
avec tous vos amis votre famille même
professionnel dentiste mais si des
personnes ne soient pas dans steam vous
pouvez les faire venir
ce soit par sms par email et compagnie
bien vu ces centrales est ce que pour
autant maintenant ça va vraiment
fonctionné comme ça je sais pas en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que microsoft
pousse ces outils ici et dans l'idée
pourquoi pas le huitième point c'est la
nouvelle interface paramètres je la
trouve globalement plutôt bien organisé
on trouve ce qu'on veut un trait très
facilement voyez vous avez en votre
laptop la part belle est vraiment mieux
contre microsoft on vous pousse à avoir
un compte microsoft a utilisé microsoft
365 avenir sauvegardés dans one drive
l'idée c'est pas mal mais je trouve que
le design est un peu dans notre temps
vous et des tout petits pictos sur sa
très austère sur la droite tout ce qu'on
va retrouver affichages sont en fait je
trouve ça triste c'est dommage parce que
on fait une belle mise à jour sur
windows et je trouve que l'interface là
dessus est pas belle alors autant vous
avez plein de choses les menus sont là
c'est pratique mais c'est pas sexy et je
trouve ça austère et en 2021 je trouve
ça dommage parce que une fois de plus
cette interface là elle est faite pour
durer dans le temps pendant bonne année
c'est aussi une expérience logiciel qui
est optimisé pour le gaming alors pour
le gaming vous en avez plein vous avez
le xbox game places disponibles il
cherche vraiment à pousser sa microsoft
je suis pas joueur donc je vais pas
jouer aujourd'hui sur ma machine mais
pour autant microsoft cherche vraiment à
vous emmener dans son univers qui volent
dans les points qui m'intéresse c'est le
microsoft store que vous allez venir
retrouver juste ici alors le microsoft
store c'est le catalogue d'applications
de microsoft vous êtes censé tout
retrouver en fait vous ne retrouvez pas
tout mais il y en a de plus en plus et
ça vient pas mal d'applications disney
plus à retrouver un netflix bon avec
toutes ces compagnies why not pourquoi
pas prêts à une vidéo elle instagram des
applications android qui arrive ça tend
à devenir plus simple plus complet plus
intuitif à voir ce qui va arriver bien
évidemment mais en tout cas ça semble
plutôt aller dans le bon sens discorde
que vous installez et peut-être qu'ils
vont réussir à dire tout centraliser ici
pour éviter de venir télécharger à
droite à gauche jusqu'à s'est intéressée
par cette mise à jour de windows rose
mais je trouve qu'on ne va pas encore
assez loin est-ce que ça suffit de venir
mettre votre menu démarrer au milieu
est-ce que ça suffit d'avoir une
expérience plus épuré c'est déjà mieux
on se rapproche un peu de l'idée d'un
mac os avait quelque chose de plus
simple plus épurée qui conviendra
peut-être à plus de monde je sais pas
parce que je pense que les puristes de
windows risque un petit peu de râler
mais comme à chaque fois dès qu'il ya
des modifications vous avez plein qui
vont pas forcément être d'accord et qui
vous dire c'est pas bien c'était mieux
avant bon ok je suis d'accord avec ça
alors après rassurez vous si vous
utilisez un windows 10 il va continuer à
être mis à jour pendant des années dont
vous pourrez rester sur votre windows
dit vous avez largement le temps de voir
venir mais ce qu'on voit ici est ce que
microsoft nous montre il était temps de
faire évoluer ses pc se rapprocher
également peut-être plus de mobilité ont
je pense à la gamme surface qui vont
avoir des fonctionnaires qui vont être
dédiés que je vous ai pas montré ici
parce que je n'ai pas de pc surface tout
de suite avec moi on en reparlera parce
qu'on se testera les prochaines surface
donc on regardera ça plus tard donc
venez vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas il faut que microsoft rend sono
est plus sexy ils deviennent un peu plus
sexy mais je pense que sur le chemin de
la sexy fication il ya encore du boulot
est ce qu'il y aura des évolutions
intermédiaire dans windows rose ou alors
est-ce qu'il faudra attendre windows 12
dans 4 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans pour voir enfin
vrai sexy fication microsoft je sais pas
allez savoir alors dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez ce que vous pensez que
c'est sexy windows est ce que vous êtes
utilisateurs de windows est ce que vous
pourriez switcher si vous n'êtes pas sur
windows si vous êtes peut-être sur linux
ou même carrément sur mac os qu'est ce
que vous en pensez est ce que ça
pourrait vous donner envie de venir
utiliser windows marquer ma tout ça bien
évidemment on bat aux commentaires et
nos autres bientôt pour parler d'autres
machine de microsoft parle de hardware
on parlera de pc aux parades de gamme
surface parce qu'à plein de choses qui
sont arrivées et c'est vachement
intéressant et on regardera comment est
ce que microsoft a intégré windows dans
ses machines propriétaire et ça c'est
cool sur ceux des bisous de l'amour
portez vous bien un et a très vite mis
ko
[Musique]
déclinée